a
[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france24 la
gordo fobia es cada vez más ampliamente
reconocida como un sistema de
discriminación y de violencia estética
una presión social que afecta
principalmente a las mujeres en un
entorno de consumo y publicidad que
vende cuerpos delgados son las curvas un
problema vamos a conversar sobre este
tema y sobre las implicaciones en la
salud mental de las personas
precisamente para el debate se conecta
al aura agudelo más conocida como la
pesada de moda ella es activista contra
la gordo fobia bloguera y también
instagram air en bogotá colombia y
también está conectada con nosotros
looks moreno filósofa escritora
representante del activismo gordo y por
la diversidad corporal y también autora
del libro gorda vanidosa sobre la
gordura en la era del espectáculo ella
está desde buenos aires argentina
muchas gracias a ambas por estar en ella
soy bienvenidas y looks voy a comenzar
con usted que es una persona gorda
porque la publicidad de la moda los
medios de comunicación casi que nos han
clasificado a todos con esa
característica más allá de los
estándares médicos somos una sociedad
que siempre quiere estar más delgada
sí exactamente gracias angela cuando
hablamos de que es una persona gorda en
realidad es una especie de misterio con
ojos le decimos porque si hablamos de
personas gordas las personas gordas son
las que aparecen patologizar por el
modelo médico hegemónico cuando aquellas
que tienen un índice de masa corporal
esa relación del peso y la altura al
cuadrado que es mayor a 25 puntos
hoy en día igual si lo pensamos en los
medios masivos de comunicación social la
gordura es otra esposa la gordura tiene
que ver con todo aquello que escapa
digamos a los modelos hegemónicos una
debilidad es que es casi en el rango de
las anorexia es esto de hecho se vio
mucho los años 90 con todos los
movimientos de las supermodelos y con
una masificación de estos estilos super
gente hoy en día que ser gordo bueno es
todo aquello que va por fuera de esta
norma súper estetizada que tiene que ver
con la delgada de saber porque hoy uno
podría decir bueno kim kardashian
señalado como una persona gorda sí o no
en realidad quién kardashian representa
parte de esas hegemonías corporales y
tiene que ver por el lugar también
hegemónico en el que estar en relación
en la exposición y visibilidad de su
cuerpo y en el exitismo y eso es pese a
ser una vía verde de curvas prominentes
laura exactamente una curva sí sí sí
bueno que quisiera ver precisamente
estaba hablando la elaborada porque
quisiera que también nos dé su punto de
vista ya no solamente de que de ser
gorda sino laura que es la gordo fobia
bueno pues la gordo fobia es como una
cosa que se ha normalizado
y qué
así que se ha generalizado que las
personas gordas son perezosas no tienen
buena salud comen mal
son aburridas
y en algunos casos y esto por favor
quiero que no me lo van a malinterpretar
porque y esto hablando específicamente
del tema de la industria de la moda como
son las personas cortas todas fueran
pobres que no tuvieran suficiente
capacidad adquisitiva para comprar ropa
que por ejemplo es el tema en el que yo
me desenvuelvo
muy bien y continuando con el tema looks
no es lo mismo ser una mujeres con
sobrepeso que ser un hombre con
sobrepeso las críticas no vienen con la
misma intensidad no son igual de fuertes
somos las mujeres más víctimas de gordo
fobia
sí y somos víctimas más crudamente de la
gordo fobia específicamente porque
estructuralmente el sistema en el que
vivimos nosotros formado en objetos de
consumo es decir que nosotros debemos
lucir bien para poder acceder a lo que
es el mercado de deseo en el caso de las
mujeres gordas primero son tachadas en
ese lugar que es el mercado de deseo y
luego es recrudecía esta mirada para
todos los cuerpos se dicen realizadas
todas las corporalidad es que quiere
decir que no importa si somos más o
menos oro siempre tenemos la amenaza de
poder ser una persona gorda y que eso de
ser gordo como bien lo decía
laura tiene que ver con
ser estigmatizados socialmente y eso
puede ser o sea desde el hecho de no
conseguir o sea de no tener ropa para
vestirnos hasta no poder acceder al
servicio médico de salud en especial las
mujeres hay una cosa muy violenta que
tiene que ver con el señalamiento
constante sobre esas corporalidad es el
cuerpo se vuelve hay una plataforma
opinión pública o sea cualquiera puede
venir y así te estás comiendo mal porque
no bajas del peso porque no se es una
dieta etcétera miren las imágenes de
apoyo que estamos utilizando luke
supuesta han pasado varias tomas de
imágenes de cadenas de comidas rápidas
de gente en los mercados y es que si
viene está claro y está demostrado que
la talla de las personas ha aumentado en
las últimas décadas y eso tiene que ver
con la forma en la que nos alimentamos
nos han hecho creer que perder peso es
necesariamente un sinónimo de salud aún
cuando esa pérdida podría implicar
desórdenes alimenticios desórdenes
hormonales daños a nuestra salud mental
y eso pasa incluso quisiera decir
preferencialmente en los consultorios
médicos cuáles son esos sesgos que
ustedes dos encuentran que deben cambiar
los doctores y comienzo con ustedes
looks
algo que nosotros acá en argentina
estamos empezando a hacer se publicó
hace muy poquito la primer guía de
sensibilización para diversidad corporal
gorda en la provincia de buenos aires y
este manual de sensibilización tiene que
ver con la atención primaria de la salud
en territorio es decir en barrios
vulnerables
esta propuesta lo que tiende a hacer es
a empezar a hablar de cuál es el tipo de
tratamiento que tenemos sobre las
personas en general y específicamente
sobre las personas sordas que al albero
la persona gorda un profesional de la
salud la manda directamente a la balanza
o ha pasado se había realizado hace unos
meses ninguna mujer fue accedido a una
consulta ginecológica el profesional de
la salud la vio y le escribió en una
receta vaya a la nutricionista baje de
peso como si los síntomas que tuvieran
no fueran válidos por su contextura
corporal esto lo que hace es que la
atención hacia las personas gordas en el
ámbito de la salud sea más pobre y esto
qué quiere decir que tengamos después
diagnósticos que terminan en cirugías de
interior bariátrica estas reformas los
famosas mangas gástricas bypass gástrico
del balón que hoy en día no tenemos
protocolos posteriores a las cirugías
entonces qué pasa o sea estas personas
van a hacer eso y en general aparecer un
montón de enfermedades asociadas a las
intervenciones quirúrgicas que no tienen
nada que ver con el peso entonces
extender de persona no significa no sea
mejorar la calidad de vida muchas veces
y de hecho no se habla de la obesidad
metabólicamente saludable no y es que
una de las grandes preocupaciones de las
grandes compañías que promueven estos
instrumentos médicos y estas cirugías
bariátricas es que muchas de estas
cirugías no tienen éxito al mediano y a
largo plazo porque el tema cuando se
quiere tratar el sobrepeso pues es un
tema más de salud mental el que se debe
tratar que el tema del peso en sí mismo
y por eso laura pues él le quería
preguntar más sobre esta vida saludable
y feliz que se defiende desde el
activismo gordo está en principio el
activismo gordo laura en contra de la
pérdida de peso
no yo creo que es que ese es un tema que
se ha confundido
yo soy una mujer gorda que hace muchos
años no toda mi vida ha sido porque hace
muchos años soy gorda imagínate todo lo
que me ha pasado a mí cuando voy al
médico
que lo primero que me dicen es que
obviamente una vez un médico ni siquiera
se ha sentado en el escritorio y al
verme lo primero que me digo es está
bien le va dar un infarto
y yo me está así yo había ido a una
consulta médica normal el rutinaria que
me hago todos los años y el médico sin
ni siquiera
abrir ni siquiera la aguja de donde
estaba mi nombre es lo primero que me
dijo al verme desbordara que ya me va a
dar un infarto es áspero perfecto
entonces ese tipo de cosas pasan
obviamente hay que educar a la gente y
hay que educar a los médicos de que es
para un montón de personas pero
pero yo también creo que parte de la
educación es demostrando en el mundo
obviamente que si somos que pues que
existimos que tenemos vidas
muchas saludables y que no
necesariamente ser flaco es sinónimo de
estar saludable iniciar gordo de
sinónimo estar gordo y eso es súper
importante que toda la gente lo sepa y
por eso es importante que hagan este
tipo de entrevistas y que nunca se
pierda pues el impulso de seguir
haciendo y de seguir como evangelizando
digo yo alrededor del tema que las
personas cortas existimos
algunas no hacen ejercicio otras y hacen
muchos otros se cuidan muchísimo con la
comida pero igual existimos tenemos que
salir a la calle entonces es un poco
como el respeto no lo que hay que
empezar a
hacernos más persistentes en el tema del
respeto hay que respetar el otro punto y
además que el sobrepeso no siempre está
asociados directamente a la dieta o al
tipo de alimentación de una persona
puede haber muchísimos otros factores
incluyendo pues las herencias que
tenemos de nuestras familias finalmente
laura la asociada
la gordura se habla de ella cuando se
habla de fealdad pero esa es una
construcción cultural que hacen ustedes
desde el activismo gordo para derrumbar
ese patrón de estética más usted es la
obra que está tan interesada por el tema
de la moda
mira yo agradezco muchísimo lo que pasa
con los medios de comunicación me
encanta el trabajo en medios de
comunicación pero grande en gran medida
los responsables de todo ese odio y de
todas
estereotipos estigmatización que se
tiene alrededor de los cuerpos gordos
sobre los medios de comunicación en
colombia existe solamente en este
momento una persona corta que ya no es
tan gorda en televisión que es la que
históricamente ha estado en la
televisión
porque no hay no hay como ese permiso y
cuando quiere meter al yo entonces lo
que den adelgazar y la historia feliz
por ejemplo en las telenovelas la
historia feliz es que la chica era corta
pero fue feliz al final cuando sea el
caso
el mismo caso de betty la fea la chica
era brillante y todo pero como no se
arreglaba bien y 17 fue feliz cuando ya
terminó cuando ya se transformó su novio
bonita a mí yo celebro lo que pasa con
las redes sociales que nos ha permitido
mostrarnos a todos por los flacos crespo
sospechosos causa con todas las formas y
demostrarle al mundo que hay
otro tipo de belleza que la belleza no
es una sola y que hay que salirse a ese
estándar estético en el que nos dejamos
meter pensando que la belleza es una
sola y que tienen una sola silueta
cuando hay muchas formas de la belleza
hay muchas siluetas que iguales son
saludables y que viven y que viven bien
que tienen vidas normales pone mito
y ya para cerrar el programa looks
quisiera hacer una declaración y que
usted después me de las conclusiones o
lo que usted piensa de ello y es no se
habla del cuerpo de las personas
exactamente o sea cuando hablamos de que
no hay que opinar del cuerpo de las
personas tienen que ver con dejar de
fomentar esta violencia gordo fobia por
un folk a que estigmatiza a las personas
y que así que muchas personas no quieren
acceder al sistema médico de salud no
llegan en condiciones
lastimosas precisamente por toda la
violencia estructural que que uno va
sintiendo en cada esto y esto es para
todos los cuerpos no solamente para los
cuerpos gordos o sea hay todo el tiempo
una necesidad de estar corrigiendo el
cuerpo y esa necesidad de corregir el
cuerpo ha llevado digamos a personas a
trastornos de la conducta alimentaria ya
la segregación total de las personas
gordas en el ámbito cultural y como muy
bien decía él ahora necesitamos
representaciones que representan cuerpos
diversos que representan cuerpos gordos
para poder empezar ahora a dar esta
violencia que es estructural
pues muy bien muchísimas gracias a ambas
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo en el
programa para la despedida simplemente
dejo una frase en el aire para que cada
televidente y ustedes mismas puedan
seguir reflexionando en su casa y es que
tanto daño nos hace la cultura de la
dieta en nuestro estilo de vida gracias
a ustedes gracias a nuestros
televidentes por estar una vez más en
ellas hoy nos vemos próximamente en
france24
[Música]